let's talk about the jonas brothers just
hours after they kicked off their las
vegas residency our cassie delora caught
up with the guys at the opening of their
sin city restaurant it's another e.t
exclusive i'm a circle for you
your parents have been supporting you
guys all your career now you're here to
support them how much fun is this how
proud are you it's a family affair the
idea that we can all be here together
support them they've been working so
hard on this we're obviously honored a
family affair is right the boys were
joined by brother frankie kevin's wife
danielle and their daughters and of
course their parents kevin senior and
denise this is their second location of
nelly's southern kitchen located at mgm
grand a restaurant inspired by the joe
bros's great grandmother nick said to me
this is the perfect city
for a nellie's because after you go have
a good time
you need that southern cooking to just
help make you feel better in other words
some really great drunk food exactly
[Music]
now you guys have enough grandkids for
jonas 2.0 would you be down absolutely
in fact
we had four boys we already have four
granddaughters and so we're so thrilled
i hear you are the favorite uncle i just
never grew up i'm the fun one
[Music]
what a man
all these years later you guys are still
making music together you're all fathers
you're all husbands is this the life
you've always dreamed of and prayed for
for each other
definitely happy we're having here now
for sure it's larger than we ever
expected
you